...The Fuck?
Eh?
Maybe? Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and--
Ok!
Hi Samuel Hayden, thanks for pinging in just as soon as I got back from the other world.
You're moderately creepy, and I've discovered some things about you and your...value of human life,
Which isn't very high.
"Knowledge is power."
"Baron of Hell"
Eh, I guess I wanna learn about the Baron.
So...
Tsk, I'm assuming...that that...while the nature of the.....
(Demonic Chanting)
Okay, so... I'm assuming that, from what Samuel Hayden has told me, and everything else that I've seen about this
That things are-were none too good about that expedition,
and might've been doomed from the very get-go.
I just wanted to see if there was any place over here that I could go...
BUT, apparentally not, so let's skedaddle our way back into the UAC Facility,
And see--whoa.
Hello!
Hmmm, it seems that I've blown up a lot of shit.
Or at least the demons have, since I've been gone.
OOH!  There's a rune over there.
Woh...
Hi!
Hehe, what're you doin' there??
Ya cack-o-demon douche!
Awww, ain't ya cute, I'm gonna...
Yep, little bit a'--
BbbAHH-hyeh!
Okay.
And now that that one's done...
Uhh, my ammo situation ain't doing the world's best.
Okay, then.
So, I gotta figure out a way to get some more ammo real quick,
which probably just means I'm gonna chainsaw someone in the face.
Buuut, there doesn't seem to be anybody worth chainsawing...
in the near future...
OOHH!!  You wanna be chain-sewed!?
Okay, bye then...
Man, it's like they know what I'm about to do to them, and they're running away as fast as they can.
Alright, fine.
Hep!
Hebadoo!
Any secrets? Probably, yes.
Umm, bobbita-boop?
Nope!
Apparently not.
OOHH, it's a cack-o-demon herd!
Look at 'em, fluttering off into the distance!
They're beautiful.
Oh, can I make that jump?
Holy shit.
Hup!
Byaahhhh!
Apparently, yes.
HEEY buddies!!
I need a friend...
You wanna come and be my friend..?
Man, it just seems like everybody's running away!
No one wants to be my friend!
Mmh.. Now I is sad and alooone...
Ahh...boink!
I hear growling!
'EY!!  Alright, bye then, geez...
Just a buncha douchebags off on their own...
Without any care for MY emotions--hello.
Thank you, Helpy Helperton!
I'll be taking this into my private collection of dead people things.
Because that's the kinda guy I is.
Hello!
*See's a new... toy, to play with*
OoooOOOOOooh...
*pleased elephant*
OHHHH
Hello baaaby, how you doin'?
Ohh, what a delight you are!
Now, here I thought...
I thought that this--ooh!
Is this, wait, is it the same...ammo as...what is that, eight?  Yeah.  Eight.
Yeah, it's the same ammo as the Heavy Assault Rifle, but something tells me this is gonna be way more damaging
Now what I--
*interrupted mark is interrupted*
Uh-huh.
uhuh.
Keeewl!
I'M Mark!
That's my name...
Okay, thank you.
Thanks, VEGA.
Uh-huh.
80 kilometers?  That seems kinda far...
OKAAY...
This is a lot of infermation for my demon-'thploding brain to comprehend...
Alright, so this apparently is the same ammo as the other thing,
but that doesn't mean that it's gonna be any sort of a hindrance for meee...
So, what I need to do is I need to find some enemies with which to test this out on.
Hellooo?  Anybody hoome? Mwaha!
Moo-hoo-ha!  Moo-hee-ha-ha!!
Okay.  No?  Alright.
HALLOOOH!!
POW!!
Hehehe...
Kinda slow.
Maybe it--yeeeah, it speeds up, speeds up, speeds up!
POW--Holy shit, I blasted him to infinity.
Alright, I need somethin' from you.
'SCUSE ME.
*chuckle* Thank you, sir.
Ohh, man, I don't--Ooh, I have enough ammo for you!
Get ov--what?  N-AWW, not you!
Not what I wa--I wouldn't waste that on a cack-o-demon!
What good would that do anybody involved?
The answer is nothing.
Boink!
Ah, shit.
Hep!
Hup!
Hang on.  I gotta get around.
Boink!
Ahh, those direct hits...
Oh, I need...
That's not what I need!
There we go! That's the thing!
It's a little harder to--Whoa! What?
Di-was I standing next to an explodey-barrel?
Ehhh, shit!
Okay...
It's a little harder to, uh...hot swap weapons when I got...gotta keep one hand on the mobility.
Because I have to keep one hand glued to wasduh (WASD), or else I'm not gonna be able to...
dodge everything that's coming my w-- This is OBLITERATING these guys, by the way.
This is nuts.
OHH, you were being here!  I didn't even notice you!
Sorry, buddy.
I meant to give you-- WHOA, he's dead QUICK!
This does a hell of a lot of damage.
Hello!
Aww, you and your other friends didn't survive this so good, so...
What makes you think YOU'RE gonna be okay?
AHH!
What, did--did I really just smash his head between his cannons?  That's awesome.
I'm a badass...
Aight.
So, now that I came here...
Wooh, that's pretty.
I'm assuming that's where all the demons are coming from,
'cause I can see just a LITTLE bit of their world up in the top there.
Alright, let's see where I'm going...
To the left, seems like something...
Oh...both directions could be something, so lemme try this way fiiirst...
Juuust in caaase...
It seems like the less likely of the two options.
Hop!  No!?
That's un-climb-able!  It's impassable!  There's NO WAY anyone could climb that!
I guess I'll go the other way then...
*inhale* Hello?  Anybody over here need a beating?
Hellooo?
Anybody at all??
No?? Alrighty then...
UH OH.
WUH-OH.
W'OH, SHIT.
Boink!
How 'bout you just--thank you.
Thaank you.
See, it looks like he's about to miss.
It looks like he's being all smart and dodging my shit.
Woop-bam!
Ohohoho, too bad for you.
Shoudna stood so close to that bar-rell.
Whoa, hello.
Bobbiti-boo, boink!
There we go.
OHH, I just realized... I'm in the...
I'm in the same area, I just--it just became familiar to me, I don't--I don't know why I didn't notice that before.
But this's--this is...uh, the same area...
as before, it's just a little bit...in shambles.
Yeah, so this is where I--I got the last of the, uh...
The hell-rifts, or whatever you wanna call 'em,
the little--the little mouths that...brought in more and more demons.
Which, this does mean, though, that...I finally am at the right place to have the jump boots,
for the things that I saw before that obviously needed jump boots.
Ahh, interesting...
Okay.  So, if I take into account all of that new information that I just poured into your brains...
The ideal way to go is probably over there, but I'm gonna hit this rune first...
OOOH!  What are you?
UMMM...
YOU! Wax really philosophical for an AI.
I mean, why do you need to be talkin' so much about bullshit that no one cares about?
"In-Flight Mobility" Ahh!
Ehhh, that doesn't seem too helpful.
I can already pretty much get anywhere that I need to go with the double jump.
But, maybe there's gonna be something else to it.
Buuut, I'm always up for a challenge.
Okay.
"Collect 15 Hell Relics"?
What the hell is a Hell Relic?
I don't even know what that means!
Okay, here we go!
Ohhh, it's a jumping puzz-gle...
Alright, I got this.
Easy peasy lemon squeeeze me.
Uh-huh
I know.  I know.  I know.
I know.
Hup.
Ahh, boy.
Aa~ahhHHH fu-AAAHH!!
NOO!  Why didn't I grab onto the edge!?!
What the faaahk?
I was sposedta grab onto that edge!
That was a loada bullshit, why didn't it do that?
Eh, whatever, I'll do it right this time.
'Cause I ain't no quitter.
And I definitely ain't no failure.
Maybe
Maybe be-they gave me the Super Shotgun because if I fire it in mid-air,
it'll like blast me a little farther than anything else would.
Could be the solution.
Who knows!
Alright, I'll play this safe.
Hop.
Eh.
Ehhh-boink!
Okay!
That was easy.  God, that wasn't even a challenge!
That wasn't anything!  These are supposed to be tough!
And yet, here I am.
At the peak of success
With all these victories in my....
Pants.....
Anyway
Carrying on, come on! I wana get back into it.
We got story to uncover!
Uh O
There we go.
Okay.
I thought it froze for a second there.
Okay. So, if I'm not mistaken
That's locked off ,
But it won't be locked off after i touch it.
Okay
Alright. Do I wanna go in here though?
Uggh, there's probably other secrets, but if it's like any of the other areas its probably gonna be open ended
and I can explore anything any time I want.
So I'll do that
Oohoo!
Woah hohoh!
Hehehehey! How's it goin'?
Ah, shit!
God-damnit I keep doin' that.
Heeeey! How 'ya doin Crazy Larry?
Haaahhh...boop!
Ohp, didn't bother him a little bit.
He's doin' just fine, he's havin' a fun time.
With a little candle over here.
Okay.
Oh, wow.  Eugh.
Sometimes I don't even stop to pause to look at how gross the environment is.
Ugh, that's someone's back!
Uggh, it's just a back!
Alright.  Whatever.  Manly-man time.
Hah-boink.  Okay.
Wwhhaa-eeey!  How's it goiiin'??
I saw you in a classic map!
WAAH, HE'S COMING RIGHT FOR ME.
How 'bout this?
Hoohohohohwah!
*giggling*
Oh, shit.
Ow.  OW!
That guy actually hurts!
Whoa--AHH!
Oh, geez!
How di--He charged a hole right through me!
I wasn't ready for that.
Okay...so...umm...
Whoa-what the FUCK??
Ohh, my God!!
The game just crashed!?
Okay, we are back.
Sorry about that, I've never had this game crash before.
It's very interesting that it did, and it didn't even give me an error or anything.
So, let's face this uh...
Demon.  Once again.
Hi, Pinky! How you doiiin'?
Oh I've got a present fer you, as soon as you get close...
HahaHAhaha, okay.
Weeell, that's--wohohohoho!
That was a bit excessive, don'tcha think?
He's just a little cutie!
Why would I be worried at all about THIS little c--whoa.
Hi.
Okay, you know what?  I'm not gonna...
Not gonna--whoa!  Hey hey, buddy.
Uh oh.
Uh oh!
UH OH!!
Hey.
STOP that, you dick!
And stop fth-spawning!
Too many of you!
AHH!
God dammit, fuck you.
They're hard to avoid.  They're very inconsistent speeds.
Whoa!
What!?
That wasn't even a charge!
OHH, fu-OH FUCK YOU!
God dammit!
Screw this and screw you!
Okay!?
EAT DOOOONG.
Wow.  They, like...they buffed Pinky by a LOT.
'Cause, you used to--you used to street-sweep Pinkies.
In the original DOOM, you us-you used to just like...clear the entire rooms of Pinky with just a simple shotgun.
But...Goddamn.
Pinky no...Pinky no goofin'.
Pinky is no goof.
Pinky is an un-goof.
Okay.
So now that that's taken care of...
Hot tits!
Alright, finally!  We got past that.
Wow.
Oh, hello.
No, just, just don--you're embarrassing yourself.  Stop it.
You're not anywhere near the level of Pinky-ness.
'Cause Pinky has reached a new ascension of douche-nozzly.
Oh, what is this?
"Airlock sealed"?
Whyyy?
I want to go throoough!
Alright, gimme some goddamn health.
An-and gimme-give me the skill with which to not embarrass myself in front of a bunch of people.
Alright.
Ooh, Samuel Hayden.  Alright.
"Before Samuel Hayden 'died'," by the way, he "died" and got implanted into another body...
Mm-plegh!
Okaaay...
Okay, that just means that I'm gonna fight this dude.
That just means that I'm gonna kick this dude's aaass at some point.
Oh... Oh, okay.
Hi, Pinky!
Hehy-Pinky..!
Are ya gonna poop out a yellow card for meh, baby?
*chuckle* Y-Is that what you're gonna be doin'?
Oh...
Ohh nooo...
Ohh nooo, I'm gonna have to...
I'm gonna have to dig through a pile of Pinky poop!
WOOH, quad-damage!
Quad damage!
Alright, you know what, Super Shotgun for y--ohh, that's not what I wanted!
Super Shotgun!  There we go.
hoop
QUAD!
QUAAD.
Whoa-hoh... QUAD.
Anybody else?
QUAD.
No,
Quod...
Hoop..
Woo, what's up here?
QUAD.
Hello. Can I have you?
Thank you!
Always good to stop in the middle of battle to...appreciate those finer things in life.
Like a Praetor Token.
Alright, anybody else want a quod?
Aww, I'm outta quad...
Alright...
Helloow...
Umm...
Oh, hey!
What're you doin' down there?
Boonk.
Ohhhh, boink!
Thank you.
Alright.
Who else is around here?
Another one?
Your friend just died, why did you come in chargin'?
What if there--what if, in reality, there was literally only like...three of these things,
But I keep killing them and they just keep coming back?
Hey, stop that.
Doodly-doodly-doo, okay.
Ehh, those guys're done, I got an ammo cache over here, should be good for me.
Oink!  Okay.
Sooo...th--it seems to me that there would be a secret around here, but apparently not.
Okay...I'll just take the stairs up and keep moving forward.
'Cause I got a mission to comple--ohhh!
Hello!  Hi!
How you doin'!?
Boy, the Citad--that is very reminiscent of Half Life 2, and the Citadel after it exploded, you know?
It just-iiit just a little-little, just-little-seems a little...you know, seems a little..you know.  Just sayin'.
Oh.  Hi.
Ohhh noo, I am gonna have to poop it out.  I mean--
Not me, personally.
Unless I have to eat that Pinky.
And...subsequently poop everything that he ate out...
That would be really bizarre.
But, probably, in-in my fucked up world, if I had any choice over video games--
Aww, I fell in a hoole!  Shit.
I wasn't watching where I was going.
At least I found some ammo.
Where ya at buddy?
The ya are.
Bobbita-boo.
Bobbita-boo, boink!
hehehehehehe
Boink.
Oh nohohoho!
I didn't even need both that time, I just used the wowne.
Who else is here?
Hii~iii!
Sorry, you don't get to live.
Fell in the hole again, but that doesn't matter.
Jesus, you are tough.
Hawp!  But not that--that...feck!
There's no--from the--there's no "from below" kill animation like that.
God dammit.  Alright, I'm comin', just...bear with me.
There we go.
From...behind, I think??
Holy shit.
No.
Okay...
Stop.
Whoa.
Don't DO that, don't be all grabby hands about me!
Oh yeah, you're dead.
Okay.
Fahck you.
Uuhhuhuhu, I blew his arms off.
I blew his tiny, vestigial, t-rex arms off.
Alright, there we go.
Man, for some reason, everyone else just bows down before the glory and destruction that is Markiplier,
And yet, Pinky...
Pinky's just a giant dick.
Alright.
UuuUUM.
Let's see, here...
Oh, hello!
Oh, THIS looks like a fun party!  Can I join?
Bubbiti-badabuh... Lemme get the Gauss Cannon out, here.
OwaaAAHH--boinkie.
Uh oh.  That ain't good.
Boink.  AHH!
How's you, how is you not dead??
I don't wanna deal with that.
Ugh, geez--GOD, NOT THE HOLE.
FUCKIN' HOLE.
FUCK HOLES.
Right?
Am I right, guys??
Am I--AGH, FUCK HOLES!
FUCKIN' HOOLES!
Piece a' shit holes--bam.
Oh no, your face!  What happened to it?
Also, the rest of you, geuugh...
Oh my God...
Hey, buuddy...
How you doin'?
Alright, see you in the next world.
Okay...now that that's taken care of...
Because fuckin' holes fuck up my steez wherever they go!
But everything else is okay...
Alright.
MOVIN' OOON~
Movin' on...
Alright, so...
It's my understanding that Samuel Hayden is probably...
Probably...
Okay, so, there's weird experimentation going on in other places around here...
No, no, no!  No, no!  No!  Where are you going!?
No!  Stop.  That's...illegal.  Don't do that.
Heehhhgh, bang!
Aw naw, he ethploded.
Anything over here?
Anything over here?--whoa!  Hello.
What are you doin'!?
Wa-booshki!
How 'bout...a li'l a this.
Yoink!  Okay...
Wum-- ahhh, I missed
Eh, close enough.
Alright.
I didn't even know that these things were still necessary.
I thought that they would have been taken care of by everything else.
Also, I wanna look up more on the Mancubus in just a second, because the Mancubus...
Oddly enough, the Mancubus was actually a, uh...creature that was introduced in DOOM 2.
There's quite a few creatures that are DOOM 2-exclusive.
And--whoa.  Wha--Oh, I thought that was the Pinky guy.
Ah, shit.
Oh f--oh, fuck-in' gaAAHAHAH!  This not a good situation to be in!
Oh, fuck.  Me.  In the butthole!
Fuck me in the butthole!
Ohhh, this ain't good.
Whoa--AHHHHAHH, I DON'T WANNA DIIIE!!
Just gimme...gimme the goddamn...gimme the goddamn kill!!
There we go.
Oh, health esplosion!
Alright--ohhh, fuck, not another one!
AHHAHAH
Y'know what, just fuck it.  Fuckit.  Fuckit.
SPAM INC.
Call me Spam Incorporated.
Wooh, fuck, where'd that guy go?
Oh, there ya are.
I don't mind you as much.
Yes, please.  Thank you.
Huh-blebphh... Okay.
Bobbita-bobbita...bobbita-bobbita..
Whoa, what the fuck?
Why couldn't I fire?
Is it really that stun module--whooa! Another one of ya.  Alright.
I can deal.
Whoa, okay.
Ugh, shit--wooh!
Okay, nope!  Stop that!
Geez, this guy is m--a mobile bastard.
Alright, here we go.
Oop!  From the top!
Okay.
That was dicey!
Holy shit.
What the fu-oOHH!  It's not over yet!
God damn, give me a--oh, I'm all out of, I'm-I'm out of ev--AHH-HAHAH!
NOOHOHO!
I JUST SURVIVED ALL OF THAT.
DON'T BE DICK.
Dugh, fuck, I'm out of everythiiing.
I'm out of ever--WHOOOA!
Whoa, fuck, okay.
I'm out of ev-ery-thing--Mega-health!
Please!  That's what I need!  Yehehehes...thank the lohohawya...
The lawyer.  Thank the lawyer.
Ahhh, shit.  Fuck you, man.
Okay...
Hup!
Okay.  Ahhh, I'm not gonna make that, I'm not gonna make that, I'm not gonna make that...YUS!
HAYAA! Okay...
Showed him what for, holy shit...
Is it over?
Is it over yet?
Is it friggin' over?  Good God...
That was nuts!
Da'was NUTS.
That was riDONK.
I can't believe I made it out of there alive, and I...I'm pretty sure that a lot of you might agree.
How the hell did I survive that?  Okay...
So, there's a yellow door over there...
*inhale* hooh, I need to catch my breath after that.
Is that a secret or something? Why is that there, in front of me?
That's bizarre.
Okay.  So, up there is the field drone.
But over here seems to be where I need to go, so...
The way I will go...
Hey.  Stop it.
Alright...
Unless there's something else that could be, uh...reached--whoa.
*stomping sounds*
Huh. Sound like something big's on the other side of that door.
Nevermind, apparently not.
Apparently that was a big-ass lie.
O-whoa!  Hey, hey buddy.
Wha--it's okay, I'll miss point-blank.  It's-it's, it's cool.  I didn't need to hit ya anyway.
I didn't want to hit ya anyway.
Herp--aw, fuck.  Fine!  Incline, bitch.
Alright.  Theeere we go.
I need to find an easy, uh, easy target to chainsaw, because these guys are too much.
Or they're gonna take too much...gumption, to be able to smash through.
Can I get back up here?
Oh, yeah, I can.  Okay.
'Cause I need ammo bad.
I need to upgrade my ammo things way more than I need to do anything--
OHH, another rune thing!  Okay.
Well, why not?  Found a secret.
Might as well.
"Eliminate all targets, health levels are critical, use armor to survive." Okay.
Alright, then.  Eh.  I can do.
I can deal.
Okay.
I don't know what this means, but...probably just about the same as everything else in this w-game.
Mkay.
Ohhh, THAT'S what it means.
Holy shit.
Alright, then.
Uhhh, they're not gonna give me any health, are they?
Oh, fuck, of cour--of course I turn the wrong corner and don't go the right way!
Ow!
Hup, okay.
Ohh, not a Pinky, are you kidding me?
I have to deal with a Pinky??
I mean, I could even, I-I-I'm generally okay with--with, uh... With a Hell Knight, even.
I'm cool with that.  That's not the worst thing in the world, in my brain.
But, the Pinky...
I think a Pinky is actually worse than the--Ohh, fuck off!
It was--WHAT??
It was-it was stunned!
Ohh, I'm boned.
I'm boned!  I'm out of time, and I'm boned.
AHHHAH!
S'right behind me!
Oh, geez...
Where'd he go?
Oh, there ya are.
There ya are.  Geezums, okay.
Just gotta get rid of the Pinky!
Get the Pinky!
Pinky and the Brain! (Get it?)
PINKY AND THE BRAIN! HUAH BABY!!
Peaugh!  Fuck Pinkies, man.
Pinkies are such dickbags!
Holy shihit...
Least I did it.  Alright...
Showin' some skill.
Not great skill!
Just moderate skill.
Above avera--nah, average skill.
Pret--pretty fairly average.
I mean, that's what... XD everyone who looks at me says...
"That guy...is outstandingly average!"
"Boy, we should call him Marki-average!"
"He's just the-the averagest guy you could...possibly hope for!"
Alright, let's see...
"Glory killing demon drops armors."  YES.
Holy SHIT, that sounds AWESOME.  I'm glad I did that one.  That's really COOL.  I am very HAPPY about that.
Coool b-beans...
Also, I need to find wherever the hell this Argent Cell is...
'Cause if I have missed it, I am gonna be very upset...
DOOM Guy up there.
I do not even see the Argent Cell anywhere on the map.
That is...not good.
Huhh...
Well...
I guess I'm just gonna...
Find it when I find it!  Holy shit, there's nothin' out here.  Alright.
Alright!  Carrying on!
Back the way I came.
Even though, I could go down, I guess...
I dunno what the benefit of going down would be, but...
Let's give it a go.
'Cause up there didn't seem to have anything.  I need to find a yellow key.
Ohh, I know where this is.  Ahh... Okay.
So, this...
Hi~ii!  Ooh, ammo, yes please.
Why am I wasting ammo on these assholes?
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you...
Ohh, you?
Whoops.  God dammit, I keep doing that.
Stop spammin'.
Spamming's not fair.
Spamming's not cool.
*raspberry*  There we go.
Alriiight...
Doddly-da, da-doddly daa...
I am full-up on everything. Holy shit, this is awesome.
Ummm...
Well, tits!
Why did I come down here if it was just for that?? That can't have been the only reason.
Eh, mighta been...
Welp, I suppose it was, 'cause there doesn't seem to be anything else over here.
Baaack up we goooooo, back up we gooo... ♪
And, if I'm not mistaken, which I probably am...
There is going to be...some yellow up here.
*pop pop pop pop pop*
But where?
Somewhere.
Ummm, over here?
I'm a little lost.  And I was even looking at the map, I just don't know where it wants me to go.
I guess this could climb up.
But I just have a funny feeling this is just gonna loop back to the, uh...
The original area where I was before.
Oh!  No it's not, nevermind!
This is completely different!
Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier!
Welcome to the...the period where I scream in your face for ten hours, and then you diiie...
OH-hohoh, no-hoh, g-oh, oh geez I'm so sorry not really...
Alright, let's break open this one.
Pop open the champaigne bottle and get started!
I'm ready to raahck.
ohh no
oh no bruh
oh no breh
Oho, shit br--oh god, no!
Ohh, geezums!
Okay.
I'm savin' all my...my goopage.
Well, not this particular goop--this particular goopage is defined(??).
Alright.
Y'know, I'm never gonna be able to get that rune upgrade if I never even need to get--god dammit, fuck you.
Alright, you know what...
I need to...
Oop!
Uhh, buh-ba-bup-buh ♪
I guess I'll just keep hitting you guys.
Oh!  I want you!  I want youu!
Ahh, shit, whatever.  Fuck it.
It's like a fatality in Mortal Kombat; you can just choose to hit 'em once.
It's a little disappointing, but it it gets it over quicker, if they're just...not worth the time.
Stop.
Hellooo, friend.
That's... Why do I keep goin'--thaat's more like it.
Okay, he fell over.  He didn't even get to the Glory Kill moment.
I guess I coulda gotten that Haste thing.
I don't even know if I would have wanted it...
'Cause, what does Haste do?
Nothing!
Maybe it causes the recharges to go a little faster.
Eh, whatever.  All done here!
Hellooo!  Anybody in here?
Anybody at all?
Ooh, nice pile of guts you got over here, I love what you've done with the place.
How did you die??
How did this guy die?  Is he dead?
He might not be dead.
How did he die?
Wh...Did he eat so much that he just choked and died?
Fell over--
Oh.
Oookay, then.
So, that was a weird power play moment...
Not sure what the deal between those two are.
Some odd sexual tension, probably.
"Actheth granted."  Okay.
Soo--Ooh, hello.
If I'm not mistaken, I could possibly--
Oh, this is gonna lead me right back to where I was.
Okay, so then the yellow door is through here, which gets me to the tram...
THERE'S the Argent Cell!  Okay!
So I can get to it from, uh, outs--oh, shit.  I just fell down.
Okay, but that's fine.
'Cause this is worth getting.
I'm pretty sure that I can just get outside through here.
I wanna make sure that I don't miss out on it.
The--probably the reason I didn't see is 'cause it was right in front of my faace...
But--Ahh!  There it is!  Okay.
Man, that was right in front of my face.  I didn't even notice.
Eh, whatever.  Good enough for me!
I'll take what I can get.
I'll get what I can take.
Alright.
Hobbiti-hop!
Kaaay...
Hobbiti...hooop.
Umm... Well.
It's a bit of a leap of FAITH!
Urk! Okay.  Maade it!
Where are ya?  Whehere are ya?
Where are ya, ya tasty bean?
Ya down there?
Oh, there ya are.
Hellooo!
THAANK YOU.
I'LL TAKE THAT.
And ingest it.  Even though I'm very trusting of...hell energy...
he-blphh
Still dunno why this helps me, but I'll take it.
Okay, sooo...I could do with either ammo or armor.
Eenie meenie...miney...
I seem to be surviving okay, my main problem is just running out of bullets with which to shoot at things.
So...I'mma try to...fix that in the long run.
Tcchh...
Okay.
Doddly-dum, doddly-dum...
And then straight down here.
Hahhh, boink!
okay... no impact compensation necessary, alright. let's go!
les roll baby!
was there any other...
"Kill a Revenant while it's in mid-air"?
oh that's easy. well, not easy
i never even let them get in mid-air...
but I'll try my best :D
what are you doing?
caught them in a compromising scenario
(bitch stop killing mah friends!!)
whoa
stop!
don't... okay...
man, that cluster bomb is just devastating
boop
poink
poink - okay
ooh hello
can't hide from me! well you can hide from my grenades, probably, because they keep missing :3
okay, so am I comple -- wooh
what are you doing? what are you doing?
Umm, am I completely done in this area, question mark.
I think...yes?
Uhhhh....
Wow.  Okay, maybe not.
I seem to have like...missed an entire portion of this map?
Is this just gonna send me...is this gonna send me out?
Also, I missed the other...how did I miss that??
Man, I missed a lot of things.  Okay.
So, if I take this tram, this is gonna leave the area, but I haven't found--
There's literally the entirety of this map that's left!
And there's another DOOM Guy over there!
Wow.
...Am I really getting to the end of this without doing this??
Okay, now this is the t--this is the conundrum I have.  I could k-either keep the story moving forward...
Or, I could go through here and...y'know, finish out this area!
I guess...
Huh...
The only thing that I'd miss is the Praetor Suit...
Two Praetor Suits...
One of which is downst--uh, right near me.  Okay.
One of which is right over here, so I'll get that.
But...
huhh?
What??
Oh!  And the Field Drone, how do I get that??
God dammit, there's so many things that I'm not...understanding.
The Praetor Suit was...over there...
Ohh, it must've been in a different level, on this elevator.
Oh, no, it's right there.  Okay.
So, I get this... Praetor Suit...
And then I dunno how to get to that Field Token.
But I want it.
Really badly.
Okay, I'll be right back.  I-I wanna find these things so...
Ahh!
AHH, here we go!
hep...Okay, there we go!
Okay.  Got it!
hep, hup!
Mmkay.
Hey, you!
Alright, what else could I dooo?
Don't I have another--ugh, don't I have another--ooh.
Whooooa...
WHOOOA.
Ooooh....
Ah, I like that idea!
Spinning it up so that it just goes faster before I need to shoot it, sounds like a way, way, way better...
Ohh, yeah.
Oh, that's much better.
It's not exactly a fast spin.
Okay, so...
There's a lot that needs to be explored in this map, but...
Unfortunately, I'm gonna make the call that...advancing the storyline...
Is a bit more important, in my mind, than trying to find every nook and cranny.
And I know that some people would disagree with that, but I did find the majority of the stuff!
The only thing I missed was one Elite Guard.
I got the Argent Cell and everything else that I needed, so...
Eh--albeit, there ARE some secrets there that I would like to explore, and I would like to get all to the...
The other stuff...
Just for the sake of this series itself, and you guys watching, I want to advance the story going forward.
Okay.
So, we might find out what this whole "Lazarus Project" was set out to achieve.
'Cause we're going to find an artifact.  An artifact that Olivia was studying.
Probably the reason why she, personally, became quite possessed.
And, if we find that out, then hopefully we can find some other stuff....
About the why, and the how, and the who I am...
Whoo am I...?
Nah.
Okay...
I wonder if this guy modeled his, like, endoskeleton on the physical capabilities of me.
Because, he seems to take a personal obsession with who I am,
and what I do, and obviously he's using me to help him...
Which is fine, I guess, because m-our goals kind of meet together, and me...
Stopping the whole hell-invasion, and all that jazz!
But, other than that, I...I guess...
With the inevitable betrayal that's uh--th-definitely gonna happen.  There's no way...
Oh, hi.
Ohhh, I'm so sorry for you guys.
There's no way that this won't end with him betraying me.
Oh, hey.
Sooo...
Ah, whatever.
I've g-I've got other thoughts about it.
*mouth fart*
See, why does he explode just because you pull out the...attachments that he has?
Oh, look!  It's a bathroom mirror, but I can't see myself.
We can't reenact the moment from DOOM 3.
Oh, they had a bad time in here...
Anything else in the bathroom?
Usually, in ho--baathrooms in horror games is scaary...
No?
Nothin'?
God dammit, nothin'?
They're not even gonna do, like, a-an easter egg relating to the other thing with the...the mirror.
If y--if any of you remember in DOOM 3, like, the mirror moment?
Am I the only one?
No?
Dammit.
Okay...
Security checkpoints that mean absolutely diiick...
hellooo...
Hi~ii.
By~ye.
Hii.
Byye.
WOOH, I'll take this!
What a convenient place for one of these!
Alright, I guess I should do armor...
I GUESS, that would be the responsible thing.
Aaaand...
I'm not gonna do arm--MORE AMMO.
I need MUCH MANY more ammo.
Hallo!  BOINK.
Ohhh, that's all I needed to tell everyone that it's totally sa--boink!
It's completely safe!
No one needs to worry about undt thing!
A-and I dunno why the other demons really don't like these guys.
Maybe because they're just mindless drones that are still essentially human.
"Area Lockdown"?
"Area security not verified"?
What a load of horse bollocks!
W-I dunno about this!
But I want in there!
It's the auto maap!
And...a lot of things, apparently.
So, ahhh, I gotta the area lockdown un-disen-disen-dooged...
I dunno how to do that.
Ehh, whatever.
Hey, buddy!
Sorry...
M'kay.
So either there's another way around, or there's some security, like, clearance that I could get down the road.
I dunno which is which...
Hehy, buuddy!
Welcome to de show, always good to see a fellow Hell Knight.
Whoa...
Eh-heh...
Oh, he just fell over and died.
Oh, prolly 'cause this guy hit him.  Hehe!
What a dick!
Hurtin' his own teammate.
Hello.
Thanks, UAC Spokesperson, for getting in the way of what they were talking about.
Sure am glad that your drivel got in the way of the important dialogue,
for everyone out there who needed to read it!
Okay.
But, either way... So, they're having a little bit of a...
Moral disagreement.
Something about...Olivia wanting more faithful followers, and then...
Samuel Hayden seemed to be having some protests as to the way that things are done, but I dunno--ooh.
Did that lift the lockdown?
It mighta done it, and I might be able to go back!
That might one of those types of secrets that're just like:
"Hey, we don't think they're gonna actually pay attention and go back..."
Noope!  Apparently not.  Shit.
Hyeah!  Alright, fine then.
Onwards, and upwards, and forwards.
Got nothin' else better to do...
*tsk*
UuuoooOOHHH...sick shot breh!
*mouth fart*
No.
Alright.  So...
So far...
I haven't seen a lot of heavy opposition in what I'm doing...
So I can only assume that they're...eventually gonna get wise to...me.
And try to stop me.
Maybe.
I dunno.
Where is everybody?
Ohh, I see.  Okay, that's why.
So, I need to disable that first.
Heh-blphh... Wooh!
I'll take a Berserk!  Just gimme a second, I'm gonna get this thing first.
Sorry!  Were you guys worshipping this thing?  I apologize!
Oh, I'm sooo sorry....
This better be a Berserk.
Heehh!  It's a Berserk!
Okay, c'mere.  I got all--I got mah punches ready!
heh-pblphh
I wanna get that Mancubus.
C'mere, you!  Buddy-boo-hoohoo-ohOOHho... I punched his stomach apart!
Oh my god!
Looove meee a Berserk Paaack! ♪
(tune of "Frosty the Snowman")
It's the greeatest thiiing in the wooorld... ♪
Holy fuuucking shit ♪, they're all gonna DIE.  Ahh tits, this is really fun...
No, don't end yet!
Not yet!
Not yet!!
Not yet!!!
Awww, not in time for that guy!
Aw, it was gonna be loads of fun.
Little bit of lag on his!
That guy is playin' multi-player all the way from Hell.
Nope, nope.
Nope.
Boink.
You-re--er..
Fuck you, dude. I hate these guys.
These're little assholes.
S'all they are!
Fuuckin' assholes.
Hep!
Poink.
Huu~uhh...
Uh-oh, we got a Summoner!
Summoner!
Shit.
That ain't good.
Woh!  Don't get cornered!
A--"don't get cornered," I say to myself as I...get myself properly cornered.
Did I hit her?
I don't think I hit her...
Can you--can we lock on already??  Jesus!  That took forever!!
Where'd she go??
Ohh, there she is.
Did that get her?  Good.
Blam.
Blam.  Blam.
Oh, hello.
Hi, friend!
Can you get in mid-air?  Oh, no, that was in the last area. Not for this guy.
Hoop- boink!
Hi, buddy.
Ack...
Stop that.
Just to let you know, I just noticed that I-I'm actually...I'm actually doing quite well with...only using the Shotgun.
Because, it seems to be a pretty apt...
And that was--that was a hefty onslaught of enemies, but...
Just the Shotgun combined with the Grenade Launcher, like...
I-it-it pretty much handles everything you need in every situation you could possibly do.
"Do not shoot"
Looks like this guy got shot.  Because the blood-spray pattern suggests that he got 'sploded.
Oh my God!
Is this all just from one guy??  Oh no!
OHHH noOOO!
Uhghh...
Groooss...
It's so weird, because it seems like his...his...h-his skull and innards were ripped to the ceiling somehow?
And I dunno how Hell does their stuff, but...
You gotta admit, it's efficient....
at horrifying stuff...
Alright, so we need to go...
Aboooove...
And that's the only direction to go, but there's also something below...
But that's in a completely different area, so...I imagine we'll get down there eventually.
Soo we just need to keep climbing up...
And then hope for the best... Holy shit.
Here we go.  Boink!
Uh oh!  Huh.
"Tether Activation"?
Okaaay...
Sooo...
Uuummm....
This is nice. You been here the whole time, just behind one locked door?
Not a drop of blood?
You di--Not one demon got in here?
Not one demon?
You didn't have to kill a single demon in here?  It-it's so peaceful and--
Uhhh...
Okay.  Wow.  What is this?
Ohhhh...
"Ancient Sentintel"?
Well, he's got some serious armor goin' on there, but it's not the same as MY armor.
Their armor--
He does have blood on one hand though...
*whisper* hey buddy
Okaaay.
Whoa-uh...
Alrighty then!
Still a little confuuuused....
It's just oddly intimidating...
Not that I ever get intimidated.
But there I am.  "Praetor Suit.  Artifact..."
Huh...
That's so bizarre...
So, I've got a technological marvel of a suit from way gone by...
These guys have swords and suits of armor...
...Wha-just, it's confusing!
I am confuuused...
Okay!
Bye, buddy!  You have fun in your little...private area...
Doin' your little...private things, with your...
private fun.
Whatever that may be.  I'm not 100% sure, but I'm gonna carry on as if I know what I'm doing...
And I'm not just being controoolled...
Who knows!?  I dunno...
Maybe I could wake some of my buddies.
Help me kick the ass of these demons...
Samuel Hayden--ooh!  Another entry.  Okay...
Well, that's a little...narcissistic, if you ask me.
And I--You would ask me, 'cause I'm an expert on the subject of narcissism.
They call me Narcissisipa-lier...
Nar-Narcissiplier.
N-Nar-Narc-Narcthh..
Whatever.
They don't call me that, but they probably will, starting today.
Okay, so, in here, I bet...
There is something.
Exactly over here!  I almost bypassed it completely.
Right in front of my goddamn face, and I didn't see it.
Hellooo.
Well, right around the corner, but you know what I mean.
Bada-bing, bada-boom.  Anything over here?
Anything over there?
WOOH!  That looks fancy, and fun and free.  I should probably upgrade at some point.
Uuhhmmm...
If I can't get through that door, I doubt that I could get through there,
unless that's some sort of a cycling airlock.
I thought it was an elevator, but maybe nooot?
Hell-ooo?
Hiii!  De-contam me!
Why is an airlock needed here?  We're already underground.
Unless this is somehow gonna link to outs--
Ohh, it links to outs-it does exactly what I think that I assumed it was gonna do...
NEVERMI~ND.
UuhhhHHH.
Alright.
Let's kick these guys's ass and then move ooon!
*raspberry*
Thank you fer yer contribution!
I'll take this.
Can I get--I-I need...this.
Thank you.
Whoa.
This guy looks different.  Why does he have armor?
That's bizarre.
Why does this guy have am-armor??
I dunno.
Hello.
No.  Hehe!  He died so quickly...
Hey buddy!
Ohh, you don't have armor.  You're not special enough.  You're low-ranking.
Poink.
Hep.
'Kaaay...
Oh, shit!
I got hit a lot!
I dunno by what!  Oh, that guy...
Alright...
He-bep!
Agh, feck, I missed.
There we go.
Hup!
Phblplu-phbleb! Okay.
Dat done.
Uh oh, big guy comin' through.
Oh, shit, that's not what I wanted!
Heeep! Okay.
That guy shoots green!
I wonder what that means!
Is that extra bad??
Nope, he's just extra dead. *chuckle*
Hehehey, buddy.  Look at your head, comin' outta the top.
Ohhh, that's sad for you...
Eh, not really, I'm no--I'm not sad.
I'm not sad at all.
Okay, so if I still can't get through here...
There must be something else that I need to do .
These damn security breaches!  I just don't know where to go for them...
I dunno if there's something else that I need to do extraneously than what I've been doing...
Uh oh--
OHHH!
Huh-BOOF.
Okay, Ser-curity field lowered.
I guess that means I'm about to go onto the walking plains of Mars.
If that is where I'm gon-OHH, there we go, now it's open.  Okay.
So, I go through here, and I can do the challenge in this area...
And then that should probably be the last thing that I have time for in this episode, so let's bang this out.
HII~II, not really a secret!
Uhhhh.... "Movement is only permitted for 3 seconds following any kill"?
WhaaaAAAT?
Cool... *chuckle*
I like moving!
I don't like...the idea of not being able to move when I wanna move, but I-I'll deal.
We'll deal.  Alright.
I say "we." I mean "me."
beh-beh-deh
Okay.
How are you not dead?
YAAY!  Okay, that was easy!
Sorry, I didn't even...talk!  During that whole thing, I was just concentrating!
Oh well.  Whatever.
*inhaaaale*
It is what it is.  But anyway, that's all the time that I got for this episode.
We're finding more and more about this whole Argent situation.
And this Samuel Hayden...They're painting him--
Originally when I talked to him, I thought he was just another doctor who happened to be a robot,
Wh-when--but when you actually see him...and how biiig he is....
Kind of imposing!  Not gonna lie, it's kind of imposing...
Actually, one more thing that I'm gonna do is I'm going to...
Do this.
Ooh, I'll take that.
Okaay.
Got that Area Scanning Technology, just 'cause I wanted to upgrade something completely...
And then the Weapon Systems!
I've already done most for the Shotgun, so I dunno what else I could dooo...
Uummmmm....
Hmm...hmmMMMMM
Quick lock-on, most definitely faster recovery.
Most DEF.
Might as well upgrade this, 'cause I got nothin' better to do with my time!
Okay, and then that that.
Okay.  So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you in the next video!
Bye-bye! =D
*Haunted outro*
I mean, I-I probly shouldn't be so careless-- Oh, and these guys could be a little more--ja-pow!
I think it mighta seen me!
No, you-- Pa-hah!